- He was born in Brooklyn,
and has made his career
at 30 Rockefeller Plaza
in the heart of New York City,
first on Saturday Night Live,
that's where we first
fell in love with him
and now on The Tonight
Show Starring Jimmy Fallon.
His new kid's book, "Five
More Sleeps Till Christmas,"
recently hit number one
on the New York Times
Children's Bestseller list,
no surprise there.
Let's head to Midtown
for the next landmark
in the city that never sleeps,
give it up for Jimmy Fallon.
(cheering)
- Oh my goodness.
Hey!
Kelly!
- Hello.
How are you?
- [Jimmy] I'm so happy to
be a guest on your show.
You know I'm the biggest fan,
so congrats on all this stuff.
- I love your whole look right now.
Like I've been loving your look.
You're doing like the
hoodies with the jacket.
It's like, you look so cute, I love it.
- Oh, come on, stop it.
- I love it.
No, thank you so much for taking the time
and as a lifelong New Yorker,
what is the most New York thing
you've seen or found yourself doing?
- [Jimmy] Oh my gosh,
there's so many things
in New, in New York,
well, I mean, you have to
live in, in a studio apartment
if you live, if you're from New York.
If you never have done that,
you haven't really done New York.
It's the tiniest,
I don't even know how they
can call it an apartment.
It's a room.
You can sit on your bed
and also like fry an egg
on this, on the stove
and also open and close
the bathroom door, it is,
I had to live there and it was
great Midtown, right by SNL.
My dad made me live a block
away 'cause he was like,
if the weather's bad, I don't
want you to be late for work
and he thought I was going to get fired
from Saturday Night Live,
so I lived there a block away from work
and at one point, I had to find a place
to reach my hands out like that
'cause everything else
was so tiny and crunched.
But Saturday Night live has
so many New York moments
that it's been crazy for
me to even think about,
but probably my, one of my
biggest and most fond memories
was the SNL 40th anniversary party.
After, the after parties are always fun,
but this after party
was the 40th anniversary
and everyone who was anyone,
it was just crazy amount
of people were there
and as soon as I walked in,
Paul McCartney was calling
my name to go onstage
and he was there with Dan
Akroyd and Jim Belushi
and I got on stage and Dan Akroyd said,
"Kid, I've done this for
40 years, it's your turn.
You gotta rock this party."
And so there was no band,
it was just me and Paul McCartney and Dan,
we did one and we just had
people come up from the crowd
and play and jam out and play songs
and the end of the night,
we're on stage singing,
Bill Murray and Chris Rock and Chappelle
and Dave Chappelle goes to me,
"Jimmy, if you ask
nicely, I think he's here,
but if you ask, you could
probably get Prince to come up."
- What?
- And so at the end of
the night, I just go
and this was like probably
two or three in the morning,
I go, "Prince, if you're there,
I'd love to have you
come up and sing a song
and blah blah blah."
And all of a sudden the crowd
parted and this purple smoke,
I swear, it's like true.
It's almost like his legs
were not touching the ground.
His legs were just kind of floating
and he was floating
across the room and I go,
"Oh my goodness."
And he comes up and he
peels off these gloves
and he hands me his gloves
and I hand him a guitar
and not only does he play,
he plays "Let's Go Crazy."
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
I really wish in that moment
you would have like right
when he entered the stage,
peeled off the gloves,
you would've just looked and been like,
a bit dramatic, but okay.
(laughter)
- 'Cause that would have been everything.
- I guess we're gonna do this.
He rocked the house, it crushed.
It was epic.
- That's so cool too and
the, the, I don't know the,
I, I've never, I'm sang a bunch on SNL,
but I've never like, like hosted it
and, and I don't know if I will now
'cause Blake, I was in New
York when Blake Shelton hosted
and it's so much time that
y'all all spend together.
I mean, y'all are like
family, like nonstop,
so I can imagine that kind
of party where, you know,
and you've got everybody there
and you're celebrating
all these friendships
that are like deep friendships.
Y'all are around each other all the time.
- [Jimmy] You live with
each other basically
at Saturday Night Live.
I mean, we were kind of,
it's like a dorm room.
It's like Horatio Sanz
and I were office mates
and we, you know, we,
we had blankets there,
we'd stay up all night trying to write
and I remember Dan Akroyd
coming in just to say,
"Hi, you're the new guys?
Just want to say hello to you guys."
And we were like, freaking
out it was Dan Akroyd.
Like, oh my gosh.
He's like, "Do you want
me to show you where
me and John used to go?"
I go, "Okay."
And he had it, he goes,
"You know, we had all the keys
to all these rooms in SNL."
And he brought me and Horatio
into someone's office,
snuck through their window and
we're out on the 11th floor
and there's like grass up
there and like a koi pond,
it's the weirdest spot
and him and Johnny used
to go up there and write.
- [Kelly] Yeah, they were doing uh,
what do they call that?
What did we call that on tour?
A safety meeting.
That's what everybody would say.
Oh, they're at a safety meeting.
I was like, okay.
- You know what that meant, yeah.
- Okay so wait,
your girls became little
TV stars this summer
in your quarantine at home addition show.
So did they miss doing,
are they like, wait, where's our part?
Why don't we get to do it still?
- The kids, my kids didn't really know
what was going on back then.
They were just trying to mess with daddy.
They're not actor kids at all,
so they were just like, you know,
I would say like, all
right, for Andy's sake,
say good night everybody
and she goes, good morning, you know?
And just stuff like that,
just to mess with me
and just, yeah, so the next time I do it,
I'm going to hire kids to play my kids.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, that's amazing.
That's actually better
though and they're like,
that's, that's hilarious.
But wait, I have a question,
so you're sitting at that desk
and I've been to your show so many times
and I've always wondered what's,
is there something in the
desk or under the desk?
Is there something, or is it
just something to lean on?
- Not really.
I mean, gosh, it's a good question.
I don't really have a, I honestly,
I'm looking in these for the first time.
This is actually I think
it's a different desk
for this new show, but.
- [Kelly] Okay, well.
- I got guitar picks.
- [Kelly] The next time I come,
I'm bringing you something.
A stuffed panda.
(laughter)
I know the panda, I've seen your show.
I know he, and then he goes
out the doors and dances, yeah.
I'm going to bring you
something for your desk next,
some nice stationary or something.
(laughter)
- I would totally use that, thank you.
- Yes, for your thank
you, no, thank you things.
I watch your show.
All right, so what's your favorite thing
about New York at Christmas time?
- [Jimmy] It really is the vibe
and it's just a magical place.
I mean, New York City
just has that, you know,
they just go big.
I mean, it's like uh,
it's, I think the window
shopping is pretty awesome.
It doesn't get old for me,
whether it be Macy's or, you know, FAO,
or Saks Fifth Avenue,
just going by the windows,
it's all done up beautifully
and it's a scene and they
spent hours and probably years
working on those window displays.
They're just gorgeous for
everybody and it's free.
- [Kelly] Yeah and they make you, yeah,
they make you feel so happy, I'm with you.
What was like your best gift
that you still remember?
- [Jimmy] Oh, best gift definitely,
I got an electric guitar.
I'll never forget it.
I was probably 12, 13 and I got,
it was just awesome looking.
It was a fake Fender Strat,
it was red and white.
The name of the company was Phantom,
but it was, it was so cool and it was so,
I remember it being so heavy.
I was like, I didn't know
guitars were that heavy
and I wasn't even that good,
but I felt like a rockstar holding it.
It was so awesome, I loved it.
I love you Santa and I also,
my worst gift ever was one year,
I don't know why,
my Santa Claus got me a DVD
of the movie, "Big Chill."
- Big Chill?
- [Jimmy] Again, I'm like 13 years old.
So this is a movie about,
you know, midlife crisis.
I don't know why I'm on the list,
but I remember going okay.
Big, big chill, that,
people are trying to
have a baby and stuff,
like I, yeah, okay.
But I guess Santa thought
the soundtrack was good,
that I would like it.
I love it now that I'm in my forties,
but no, when you're a kid.
No, that was uh, that was not,
that was not one of my best gifts.
- That's a weird gift
that they definitely
weren't thinking of you
when they got it.
They were like, we forgot.
We forgot to get, so we
just pulled something.
But wait, let's talk
about your new book, okay?
'Cause I love, I literally,
I love Christmas.
I love Christmas books,
especially 'cause my kids,
we read every night, we're
really big into it in our house,
but I will say, okay,
it's called "Five More
Sleeps Till Christmas."
I don't want to ruin it,
but my favorite page is the last one
because literally my children
say that exact thing every,
once Christmas is over, we've unwrapped,
like that night, it's like,
it's all happening again.
So how many more sleeps till Christmas,
it literally is what they say.
- Do your kids, do your kids say sleeps?
Is that a thing in your house?
- Yes.
- I've never heard that.
- Yes, how many sleeps.
Yes.
Now that they're about to go
somewhere and they were like,
how many sleeps?
And I'm like um, yeah like
three more, like it's yeah.
- Yeah, I never had that growing up.
It was always days,
like you have three days till Christmas,
now go to sleep, you know?
But my, I was walking my
daughter home from school one day
and she goes,
how many more sleeps till
we get to go to grandma's
or something?
And I go, that's so cute.
How many were sleeps?
That's so cute.
I go, and I've always
wanted to do a holiday book,
so I go five more sleep till Christmas
and you do like aren't the
kids so excited for Christmas
and you just can't wait
to, you can't go to sleep
and then finally it's like.
(snoring)
And he sleeps, now it's
four, four more days,
four more sleeps till Christmas
and so on and so forth.
So basically she inspired
me for that book,
but I just thought it
was the cutest thing.
How many more sleeps?
- Um and it's so, it literally,
I didn't grow up saying that either,
but my kids somehow,
yeah, they always say
how many more sleeps.
So I thought this was,
they're going to freak out.
I literally just got this,
it was on my desk today
and I read it and I was like,
I got to the last page and
I was like, this is so true.
- Well, the fun part I
think about the book is too,
I leave parts in there where
you can read to your kids.
It can be as fast a book as
you want, or a slow read.
So I, trust me, I'm a parent,
I've been in the room where
it's like, okay come on,
this castle is a book, go to sleep.
Uh anyways, so, but in this one,
there's spaces, so you can go like,
and this is you know toys,
and visions of toys are dancing in my head
and then you go and just
tell a personal story
about how you wanted a toy as
a kid or something that you,
a memory that you have
so that they can be
interacting and with you
and talk about your memories, so.
- Have you ever,
this is a real question
and I'm totally gonna get,
people are going to shame me
for this and I don't care,
so there's been nights
when you're so tired
because we read every
night, but you're so tired
and then they happen to pick
a book that's like really long
and you're like, can't we go for this one?
And they pick the book
and then all of a sudden
you kind of start pairing,
you're like, oh look, skip four pages
and you're like.
- I've totally done that.
Well wait.
- You're like here we
go, and there you go,
now the bear went in, they go,
but my girls are onto me immediately.
You skipped a page.
- Me too.
My daughter was like, well wait,
what happened when they stopped by
and they'd went to the bookstore?
I go, oh, and then I literally,
I felt like a horrible human,
but once time I went, oh
baby, we already read that.
Yeah, we totally already read that.
(laughter)
- I'm just like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, you know what happens,
we read this last night,
the berry uh, the gorilla
goes back to the cage.
- [Kelly] I've totally done it.
I know and I'm like an author
of two children's books,
but I was like, I'm,
sometimes you're so tired
and so you're like, let's just get to it,
but you have done such a great job
and the space thing is actually
really, really important
and especially for like educational tips
and like having moments with your kids
and like really letting
them invest the story.
So all of is really well thought out, man
and it came from a very organic place,
like with your, with your kids
and my kids are gonna love this.
It's really, really great.
- [Jimmy] Thank you, but I appreciate it.
I'm excited about it.
It's like crazy.
I mean, my kids are now,
here's the cool part
that happened this year.
It's usually like if I had
a kid's book or an idea,
I would read it to them
and this year for the first
time they know how to read.
So my kids are reading the books to me,
which is like trippy as a parent
'cause you go, yes, I
can't believe you read.
They love reading.
I taught them how to read
and I go like, go for it
and it was just, so this
year was extra special.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
Do they ever like judge you?
Cause my daughter's totally done that
with the books that I've written for her.
Do they ever, do they ever like say like
you should have had the, the, you know,
this go here and my daughter
totally has done that.
- No, not yet.
I'm, I just, I'm starting
to get like eye rolls now
for different jokes that I make
'cause I make so many dad jokes
and I got an eye roll the other day
from the five-year-old and she was like
and I go, you can't eye roll me,
I'm, you're my number one fan.
You laugh at everything I
do, like that crushes me.
You can't do that.
You have to laugh at everything I say.
If I do a dumb voice,
you're the only person I expect to laugh.
Franny don't do this to
me, but she's uh, you know,
she gets it.
I mean, it's just, so
it's been a great ride.
- [Kelly] Oh my God,
that's so, that's so sweet.
My kids used to love
me singing all the time
and now my daughter's like sh.
She, she puts her hand up to my face.
It's like, we don't
need to sing right now.
I was like, okay.
All right, Jimmy's book, "Five
More Sleeps Till Christmas"
is out now.
You guys gotta get it,
you're gonna love it.
You're gonna love reading
it with your little ones,
or your nieces, nephews, whoever.